if you want to hear how all 500 movies
to date are referencing the trailer for
Annabelle comes home then make sure you
watch this whole video I called it I
called it back in September I did a dead
talk where I speculated possible future
conjuring spin-offs this is what I had
to say about Annabelle 3 so my guess is
that Annabelle 3 will take place while
the Warrens are away on another case
perhaps this takes place at the same
time as the conjuring 3 and the film
will focus on Judi or the nanny who
takes care of her as horse start to take
place around the house with Ed and
Lorraine not there to help Judi may have
to take on this entity on her own
cut to almost everything I just said
being true in the trailer parents lock
up the room they say goodbye to Judi
because they're going somewhere mistakes
happen and she says she sees things wait
didn't I also make a video last year
where I said they could do movies on the
whole room of cursed objects in the
Warrens home but I think this room of
trinkets is a clever way to tie the
series together and we may even see
spin-offs of other objects from this
room I mean I know I'd watch a movie
about this monkey wouldn't you cut back
to the Annabelle comes home trailer the
monkey moves okay it's not its own movie
like I originally said but in a way
having a movie where all the haunted
objects interact could be even better we
may get a little glimpse into the
history of some of these objects but we
won't get beat down with a bunch of
repetitive spin-offs that simply go from
object to object the only part of my
prediction that may be off is where I
said this could take place at the same
time as the conjuring three because I
wasn't expecting them recast Judi with a
younger actress it looks like this takes
place between the conjuring and the
conjuring two because in this shot we
see the music box from the first
conjuring and in the wide shot you'll
notice that the item that Ed Warren
places there at the end of the conjuring
2 is not there yet we also see what
looks like a genie lamp which reminds me
of the conjuring where Ed Warren
explains that destroying the objects
would just unleash the spirit within
them and that sometimes it's better to
keep the genie in the bottle safer
to be in here than out there it's kind
of like keeping guns off the street well
why not just throw them in an
incinerator destroy when I would only
destroy the vessel sometimes it's better
to keep the genie in the bottle the
rocking-chair moving on its own is a
reminder of Judy's first unpleasant
experience with Annabelle back in the
condo the wind vane that moves on its
own could tie back into Annabelle
creation which took place on a farm
house but the big thing that I noticed
here was this mannequin in the corner
wearing white robes the costume is
somewhat similar to sister Irene's white
garb in the nun but it also looks like
there's a veil so maybe it's more of a
wedding dress type thing that'll be
something that we have to keep an eye on
when the movie comes out its father
Gordon from the conjuring 2 is seen
towards the beginning of this trailer
blessing the room of cursed objects
something that had claims they do for
protection back in the first movie
that's why we have a priest that comes
by once a month to bless the room then
we've got the typewriter writing on its
own where it says miss me over and over
just like the three young people from
the opening sequence of the conjuring
saw the same message appear on their
ceiling noticing a pattern yet a lot of
callbacks to the first conjuring let's
add the Bathsheba ankle pulls in the
middle of the night which also happens
to the young girls of the Perrin family
to that list this demonic looking girl
in the trailer seems to be affected by
this projection cast on her which I'm
guessing is footage of one of the
exorcisms that ed and Lorraine Warren
used to teach about what they do at the
University finally we have the mystery
of this little girl I think you have the
wrong house there's no Annabelle here
this is B the little girl who died in
Annabelle creation who the demon that
later went on to possess the Annabelle
doll was masquerading as in order to
trick the family into providing her with
a human vessel
it looks like the demon is still using
the form of B and
times and she's even still wearing the
dress that be died if you're not up to
date on all of the things you missed in
the previous movie in the conjuring
franchise click the playlist on the left
to get up to speed on that remember to
subscribe to see ZZZ world for new
Horrors every week so you don't miss out
on the upcoming things you missed
episodes on Annabelle and Annabelle
creation ring that death battle for
notifications and I'll see you in the
next one
assuming we both survive